[Applause]
it's sold as the place where dreams come
true in zero covered China it's a dream
people raced to wake up from
hi these were the scenes late into the
night
one single case linked to the park the
entire Place locked down
everyone inside trapped and tested
if you get out this door you can't leave
for home either he says how about
playing inside all right
it's a policy pushing people to extremes
these are migrant workers at Foxconn
it's Apple's biggest supplier they're
fleeing a factory outbreak but with
public transport also suspended most
journeyed home by foot some for a
hundred miles or more
and just look at the scenes from inside
they might explain the desperation those
with the virus not allowed out basic
Services they say not allowed in
positive workers stuck together in small
dorms
[Music]
[Music]
all right but in China other priorities
must take their place behind pandemic
control zero covered the aim constant
testing the means numbers are still
proportionally tiny here but they're
double what they were last week and
there's a sense they're bracing
cases rise here so just this Collective
sense of anxiety and paranoia on the one
hand from the authorities who are under
immense amounts of pressure to control
the numbers and are taking these
dramatic interventions but also for
people who although are accepting of
this daily reality are also increasingly
weary
is one of many who hasn't risked a visit
to his hometown for over three years we
we had been locked down for many times
and nowadays the cases are going up do
you think people are a bit tired of the
zero covered measures
um yeah but I think people are used to
it because on the one hand it is good
for people's house and safety on the
other hand for example this test is
too often yeah
it's hard to overstate the impact on
lives here visiting any venue can now
feel like a risk the fear the feeling is
that things are about to get worse
Helena Smith Sky News in Beijing